foreign
I just like to bring the medium to order
um it's four o'clock and we've got a big
agenda in front of us and we want to get
through it so everyone get home
enjoy the day out there
um first of all
um
I've got David on the screen or here we
have yep I think welcome David
can you hear us
he's looking
can can you hear us David
no he's looking very blank
hey melon
we'll make it we'll make a start while
session
yes we can hear that now David
thanks
you could do you're good at your end
video and then you'll hear the audio
can you hear us now
good option
it's coming back on
is that better
we'll make make a star
first first up is the project register
and um Matt's um it looks pretty good
but do you want to make any comments on
it I think we'll follow through as we go
along
through the chair
um yeah so no doubt we'll talk about
each project in a bit more detail
um in a minute
um but yeah I guess overall
um
we've got quite a number of projects
reaching completion over the next couple
of months which is quite pleasing and in
general
um I think all the projects are tracking
reasonably well so happy to take any
questions
there's no no red dots which is a good
sign
no questions
I'd like to um
move that that report be received was a
secondary
councilor Joe Stringer
all those in favor please say aye
engaged
it's carried
first project up is Elizabeth Street
Water Services upgrade a big project
there's a text report I'll take it as
read but um Matt if you've got comments
on that
I think it was chairman yeah so
um yeah so the Project's obviously been
ongoing for a wee while now
um Fulton Hogan have now finished the
drainage up on Joseph Street
um and we're expecting them to come back
in late September in the next couple of
weeks uh to finish off the reinstatement
Works um tidy up the booms and things
like that and they've got a bit more
work around the um
intersection of Elizabeth and Broughton
Street
um and then that'll be all the works in
the road Reserve completed
in terms of the property separation I
think sort of making steady progress
um with that Terry has been working away
quite hard at getting the agreements in
place and getting the plumbers organized
and thing things over the last few
months
um it is I guess
um
taking a wee bit longer than than we had
hoped and
the the plumbers seem to be um have
relatively limited capacity to do the
work we are trying to get another
contractor on board to help with that
[Music]
um
but I'm saying that we are we are still
making a bit of progress and hoping to
have the large majority of that
completed by the end of the year
happy to take any questions
any questions counselors
councilman Phillips
I think it was General it's got a couple
of questions
um
met the infiltration basin
I was just looking at it today and
where the pipe comes in and you've got
the
where it comes into the infiltration
area there's a quite a large gap under
the bottom
is there any chance that you're going to
think about putting a flipping a flap
inside there to stop people climbing
into it
through the chair yeah that is something
that we've identified as a potential
issue and we're looking at into a
potential solution uh need to be mindful
that we don't block off
um
that too much and creative debris trap
and things like that but here we are
looking at solutions for that
um just the reshaping down the bottom
end of the oak for the Overflow
is it going to create a basin like a
hump like a reverse bump at the end of
the street is it is that what's going to
happen
uh yeah I guess so yeah
do you think that's going to upset the
residents shouldn't do no
no it'll be a relatively gradual one
so we're dropping the crown of the Road
by 150 millimeters over 60 Minutes 60
meters so it's reasonably gradual
okay so there won't be a hill start
basically at the end of the giveaway
song no I wouldn't think so no well
that's all right then
um
so so how's the um the plumbing side of
things going the housing
into the houses
um yeah I mean I think there's a few
challenges
um that we're probably
you know
um
that are not a surprise um but in
general it's it's going reasonably well
I think um Terry if you wanted to jump
in and provide any comments yeah um the
biggest challenge that Affairs in a
woman is because we've got access
agreements that need to be sent by all
the householders is actually getting
them to say that document uh and it's
it's culminated in many visits after
hours after five after seven o'clock
just to catch people because uh beyond
the fact that we're sending them through
email or dropping them through the doors
they're just not responding so um that's
proven to be difficult but the biggest
challenge is the commitment from the
plumbers they've got quite a bit of work
on on answer is why Martin just
suggested that we've we've we're almost
there getting another contract on board
that can carry out some of those work so
we're a long way through it on and hope
to know what truck and Well on target
financially on and I think will
definitely be finished by
um the end of this year definitely
I just got one more thing because the
Jacob went back
um so do you think do you think it's um
we can get it finished before before I
actually seal the road
thank you
no I doubt that yeah
like the the private property separation
is is ongoing in terms of um you know we
can only work through so many
applications at a time on the and the
the road
um the the work outside the infiltration
person isn't isn't in relation to the
private property separation it's not
really holding that up that's something
totally separate so so the parts have
been laid up to the property boundary so
it doesn't matter if we do the road ring
statement before the private property is
finished
so the question then is you it's either
October or November you've got it down
either either or right so that's the
their completion date for Falcon Logan
you know just I would have liked to have
had all the properties all sealed up and
done and dusted before we actually
physically sealed the road that was all
just just to say that
the ceiling is the last thing you really
should do
you know what I mean because it even
though even though I know that the the
property uh workers inside the property
you've still got your vehicles screwing
up with trailers and and possible
diggers coming into the properties and
so forth you know I just think that we
would be prudent if we hit it
kept it until we had everything finished
that's just my opinion of course I think
I think you know in terms of the private
property so you're correct and it is
maina Works compared to the Civil Works
that we've had in the in the street uh
and there's been very little impact up
to now and a lot of those private
property submissions don't require a
digger
it depends upon where we're making the
connection so there's not that there
hasn't been a huge impact on on what the
roading side of things has been compared
to the major Civil Works
so I I take on board what you're saying
but yeah I don't think it's going to
affect the um the ceiling of the road at
the bottom
but the large majority of the road is
already sealed
um and and we in terms of disruption and
inconvenience to the residents we
couldn't really leave it unsealed for a
long period of time while we did the
separation work
and we couldn't do the separation work
until the pipes were installed in the
road Reserve so it's
yeah I I know it's just a
a tricky situation
um
so the grass the grass Burns that are
left right
they're in a mess
why are we thinking about replacing them
once again with grass burns are we not
thinking about
putting them into gravel because
obviously the cars are parked in there
and or we're making them
so that the cars came parked in because
that Street's quite narrow when
with cars parked there
have you thought about doing that
through the chair we
have had a few discussions with
residents around wanting gravel berms um
I believe under the streetscape plan
um
these limitations around that and that's
ultimately a roading decision
rather than a three Waters decision but
we have had discussions with the roading
department on that
and previously the preference has been
to keep the grass Burns to maintain the
streetscape along there
thank you
there's probably eroding decisions
because I don't have to put put forward
any money but you know what what's the
best thing like to me it
over that winter period that the castle
parking on there was a heck of a mess
and what's to stop them from doing again
next year you know like at the end of
the day this street is the first street
that we've done right so we need to
think about when we walk away from that
street it's complete all the residents
are happy the road's suitable for
parking the road's sort of suitable for
driving up and down because it's a main
thorough Road through
basically to the town from that part of
the West School
yeah like a
to me it
it would seem senseless they're going to
go back and then think about the road
room itself after the grass is mixed up
in the winter time all muddy and then
having to put
put the gravel on
just um Steve if you want to come in
yeah Mr chairman I think it might be
helpful if
um we put forward a separate report
either to this committee or the council
outlining the options available rather
than trying to imagine something on the
hoof what I'm thinking here is that it
could well be a hybrid option having
regard for your
um streetscape policy but it may be that
there's a mixture of kidney Sun green
areas and actually introducing more
gravel
berms so that you can satisfy both the
demand for Austria or for street parking
or street parking sorry street parking
as well as getting making a form
decision around the the type of
streetscape and Landscape you want to
see because you do it for one street
there may well be request for a similar
approach being made elsewhere and hence
the need I think to just tread carefully
and so I think it after receiving this
report you may want to ask if they're
able or three Waters and Rowing
Department to come together and scrap it
out and come forward with a combined
View for the council to consider
well foreign
to move forward on this one do we um
wait another report from the um from
mantle from the road in people and any
comment on that Steve
yeah I think Mr chairman you just simply
uh would make a recommendation that
request the report be prepared on the
subject of
um either reinstatement
or otherwise of the grass booms in
Elizabeth Street Street having regard
for the need to provide
um street parking the preservation of a
semblance of a landscape
and mitigating issues around bogging up
of parking on the berms during winter
thank you would someone like to move the
motion in that way
never
counselor Neville Phillips would you say
the move
everybody comment got that David wanting
to comment
right
you're happy to move that we go for that
report
is there a second before that
oh thank you all those in favor please
stay on it
hang on sorry
oh you can leave it on
um just noting that in Matt's report I
think Fulton Hogan and due back
in the next couple of weeks
um so just want to reiterate that that
possibly means a delay
um I understand wanting to get this
right but that means we're pushing those
contractors back probably a month from
starting their reinstatement Works to go
through this reporting process and just
want to acknowledge that we're okay with
it
I'm sure
I also make one quick final coming I
lived in Elizabeth Street for 20 years
from 1979 to 19 sorry long that 2003
when I left Gore uh there was never any
problem with the bogging on a big scale
there was a couple of green areas that
bobbed up I was on the top of the hill
at 36 that and there are parts of the
road now where there are gravel areas
the whole Road from about 41 right to
the end is gravel right across there's a
number of other properties that have
gravel in front of them so there's a
mixture already of gravel and
grass booms and a lot of the ground up
there is pretty free draining
so
but that's my comment anyway
thank you we've still got a motion on
the books from Neville and Paul
well any more comments on it
while he put the motion then all those
in favor please say aye
against
carried
so we'll wait the report
thank you any more comments on Elizabeth
Street
someone like them to remove that report
would be received thank you
comment comment here so I was just um
trying to formulate a question for Jason
there uh is this the last piece of that
project or are we holding up the rest of
the continuation of that project
um with asking for that report
so the chair this apart from the Privacy
property separation this is the last
part we may be able to start on the
stuff uh the connection to the um
retention pong first so it buys a little
bit of time with the booms but yeah just
uh
it was part of them coming back in
September is to to crack into that as
well so we'll just we'll try and manage
that with this weekend from our end but
it may just mean again a little bit of
delay for those boom reinstatements
however they end up looking
thank you
so would someone like to re that we
remove the report be received
I'm Joe councilor stronger and we hope
to worship the mayor a second
all those in favor please say hi
it's carried
we'll move on to the next one
as the East School Water Treatment Plant
upgrade project update
um it's progressing well has already
comment from that
thank you Mr chairman
um yes obviously this Project's been
largely complete for a little while now
and we're just working through
um one noise issue with the contractor
which is taking a wee while to get
resolved but we think the design of the
solution is now pretty much finalized
and are expecting over the next couple
of months to have that solution
implemented we are keeping the affected
neighbor
informed on on progress and they seem
comfortable with that at the stage so
able to take any questions
counselor Stringer
oh yeah three Mr chair
um what are our options of the noise
remedy doesn't work for the neighbor
where to from there
through the chair so it is very much a
designer shoe that sits with the
contractor being given the contract was
designed built
um
they've sought specialist noise advice
from especially as noise consultant
who is
raised me confident that the solutions
being proposed will work
and and I I guess that's partly been why
it's taken a wee while is that they are
being relatively careful to get it right
um
I think if it does and there'll be
retesting done to to make sure that it
meets the district plan requirements at
the boundary when the solutions have
been implemented
um
I think potentially it is is further
things that can be done to further
reduce the noise if we had to
no further questions
um
I'll move it would someone like to move
that the report be received
councilor McDonnell and secondary
Council McKenzie all those in favor
please say hi
all right
against carried
I'll move on to
fourth report the Wiggum Street
Wastewater Mains replacement update
um a project looks like it's on the
finished
and any comments from there
so the chair yeah I'll just say that the
large majority of the works are now
complete and there's just some minor
reinstatement Works to be done really
um so yeah it's obviously been a sort of
Highly visible and
project completed on a
in a relatively difficult site but
overall I think it's gone reasonably
well and we're pleasing to get that one
finished off
are there any questions
no I
think yeah I never no it's not a
question just more of a congratulations
on the staff and and the contractors on
the job well done is met dissoluted it
was a pretty high profile area and I
think it was very very little disruption
to traffic flows and things like that I
think was well done
I'd agree with that too
very well done
um would someone like to move then that
would you like to move um Neville that
the report be received and as a
secondary
Mandy Fraser Council Andrew Fraser so
you can do it all those in favor please
say hi
against it's carried
move on to number five is the partial
just de-sludging of the gore oxidation
ponds project update
um any comments from Matt on that
through the chair um yeah just a bit of
an update
um the the contract has actually
finished the Des lodging works now
um
we're waiting on test results to confirm
the the final volume of sludge removed
um but it's looking like it'll be very
close to that 2 500 tons that we're
aiming for
um
and yeah once again
this project is sort of the contract is
now in the process of just establishing
from site and packing up the gear and
things like that and once they've
completed that it'll be a
um a survey done of the sludge level in
the ponds to determine
yeah they're running polymer sludge left
in the in the ponds
um but yeah overall
um I think the Project's gone reasonably
well again
just just one question
um what's the life expectancy of the
bags and what actually happens after
they
've passed their life expectancy
through this year um
so the advice we've had is that that we
need to leave the the bags uh the sludge
and the bags for sort of 18 months to
two years to allow the sludge to fully D
water
um
in and during that time
um we'll potentially look at
uh disposal options for the sludge
um
the the bags are purely for the
dewatering of the sludge
um so if they were to so they are all
situated in a P lined Basin so if they
were to burst or rip or anything like
that over time the sludge isn't actually
going to go anywhere it's still
contained in that lined Basin so it's
not an issue if they do fail
and I believe that there's some some
bags other plants have been there for
quite a number of years
okay any other questions
um
councilor Fraser
what are options available for the slash
are there any
through the chair um so one option
um is take it to landfill
um let's obviously quite
an expensive option
another option is to leave it in the in
the Basin
um and
um I don't believe there's any
significant issues with that aside from
the fact that you're using up space on
the um on the treatment plant site but
potentially that's an acceptable
solution
um and and the other options are to and
so once the sludge is partially
dewatered we'll do some testing and look
at whether there are alternative
disposal options
to take it to somewhere other than a
fully certified landfill
thank you and no further questions
would probably be a question for the
three Waters
in the future sometimes
or whatever happens
um someone like to move that that report
be received
councilman McDonnell anyone a secondary
Council Phillips all those in favor
please say aye
against carried
number six the gore and material
Wastewater consent renewal project
update
um and the report
that follows
any comment on that map
through the chair
um yeah so
um there'll be a report we're now at a
point where we've got a recommended
short list of options
um to carry forward for detailed
investigation in the report outlining
those will be coming to the council
meeting next week
um
so yeah we're sort of getting to the
pointy end of this project I suppose
um with the aim of getting a consent
application into environment Southland
by the end of April next year
um
now that we've identified those
recommended shortlist of options um one
of the KNX stages is to start doing some
investigation on potential
sites so we have been and we are in the
process of contacting land owners and
asking for permission to undertake some
testing within their properties to
determine whether or not this their
properties could could potentially be
suitable for a and for some of the
solutions
you have to take any questions
any questions out there
we've got one is um potentially is the
wetlands would that be able to replace a
billionaire plant
the cost of being an airplane is negated
by using a crater of wetland
uh
yeah so that I guess
um
there's a couple of different options
there you can have a bigger Wetland and
no BNR plant
um or MBR plant sorry
um or or have a smaller wetland in an
MBR plant
um and and those are the sort of things
that we'll be working through
um as part of the detailed investigation
thank you
no more full counseling mcfarl thank you
through the chair
um just
the the ground that we're looking at if
that is not right because of obviously
we've got the the roonoma situation with
the water that once it goes through the
wetlands into the river if we find it
where do we go to because it it's a
major problem isn't it
through the chair yeah it is a critical
um
Factor being able to find suitable land
I guess the the areas that we've
identified at at this point are
um have been identified as being
potentially suitable based on desktop
information
and also looking at um the you know the
proximity to the treatment plant and
things like that
um if these sites weren't found to be
suitable
um then there are other options we could
expand our
um the area that we're investigating and
look at alternative sites
and saying that
um for some of the options
um
there's not a massive amount of suitable
land that we've identified based off our
desktops studying
and that could ultimately rule out some
options if we couldn't find suitable
learned
through the tube they're just one
further met thing there
the likelihood of um is there anywhere
else around the country doing the same
thing and you know how
that exactly there's an example of that
working because it must be happening
everywhere
through the chair yes it certainly is
happening up and down the country
um most councils when they're renewing
resource consents are being required to
investigate land disposal options now
um and
um there's a I guess a wide range of
solutions being implemented
um
I mean if you look at um locally
um the Tiana Wastewater scheme
um the SDC have recently implemented is
a pretty good example of a process that
they've worked through and ultimately
decided on irrigation to land
and there's lots of other different
examples around the country now
caps counselor and Phillips
thank you Mr chairman uh just one
question are you looking on both sides
of the river
through the chair uh
yes
I think
the majority of the sites are located on
the
um same side as our treatment plants and
that's obviously preferred
um I think there are some sites that
we're looking at on the other side of
the river
um but yeah if we can find suitable land
on the side of the river it would be a
significant advantage
idea just said I was thinking that the
distance traveled from Tiano through to
manipuri airport you know like it was
in the land traveled through it was a
considerable distance
and distance doesn't seem to be a
problem
just the river seems to be a problem for
us
through the chair yeah
I mean
distance
adds complication and and adds costs and
things like that so
certainly the preference is to have it
as as close as possible but yeah
yeah
what what sort of another question
what's sort of criteria for the land has
got to be it doesn't won't be allowed to
be free draining or is it going to be a
play base or a
um and it's going to be above waterline
I suppose in a flood
so yeah there's different criteria for
the different options
um and and yet it is
um the criteria changes quite a bit
obviously with the Wetland which is
um one of the recommended shortlist
options
um the underlying land is not as
um critical
um and but then we need to look at
things like flood risk and that sort of
thing so
but but if you look at the irrigation
options
um that there's a fine Balancing Act you
don't want two free draining but you
obviously want some
um drainage and yes
it depends on the option yes don't any
further questions
has been expensive expensive so far and
it looks like it's going to end up
costing us a bit of money
but I mean hopefully it produces an end
product that we can work on
would someone like to move that the
report
Council mechanics just when you're using
ground like that does it get to a stage
where it's absolutely saturated and
can't be used anymore for that purpose
through the chair yeah absolutely that's
that's a key consideration and there has
been examples
um
where
the ground has become too saturated
um
and then
other councils run into issues with it's
been too many too much phosphate or
phosphorus applied to the ground which
has affected the um
a validate for the of the ground to take
up the water and things like that so it
does have to be very carefully managed
thank you
um
no more questions would someone like to
move the report be received
Council Australia a secondary councilor
McDonald all those in favor please say
aye
against
carried
I'll move on to seven
the matara river crossing project update
um another matter of your comments on
that things
through the chair yeah so um
just an update on this
um so we've recently had the um Geotech
investigations started
um at the proposed drilling location at
the end of Maitland Street
um so Terry has been looking after the
the drilling contractor there
um
we have had some challenges with that
work
in particular
um
seems to be that the
very end of Maitland Street has possibly
been
reclaimed at some stage
and so there's some full material in
there and as a result of that we need to
do some more investigation work in that
area just to understand what that film
material is we don't think it's going to
be a significant issue at the stage but
we obviously need to fully understand it
before we go too much further
thank you
any questions councilor Fraser you
through the chair are we exploring other
options as well of drilling slots
through the chair
um not at this stage
um but that's an option if
we look at if this if we identify issues
with this site
yeah so the site's obviously been chosen
because it's it's the most direct route
um
and it obviously optimizes our pipe
costs and things like that
but yeah depending on the results of
this initial investigation we could
potentially look at alternative
locations
cancel the Stringer
uh three Mr chair
um you mentioned that they're doing
drilling for testing uh just a little
question around costs for for drawing
for testing as opposed to
um doing a slip trench with a digger and
getting a profile of what your grandma
what's that how far down are they going
through the chair they're going down to
25 meters so it's the only only
practical ways is
any further questions
as worship
just with the
um reclaimed Lane of Maitland Street is
that likely to put a delay on that
completion date or we are you still
optimistic for the 16th of October for
that Geotech to be done
through the chair uh your potential will
delay that
um the completion of the Geotech
investigation work
um
but
I wouldn't expect it to delay the actual
completion date of the project at this
stage depending on what we find
okay Council Phelps
so it's probably talking about an Old
Quarry
right through to Maitland Street from
the river to Maitland Street probably
three year potentially
yeah and it probably goes all the way
back to the pump station
up there from Jacob Channel cross all
the way back up to Cooper's Wells
probably that was all Quarry years ago
how old are you
now I've seen photos yep
because it would have been incredible
extraction yeah
and then backfill I suppose
correct
any further questions
um if not
I just we had one commenter so you know
councilor McKenzie's comment of other
sites
if you go down the river to Walnut Grove
you do strike Rock don't you
across the river instead of more
suitable site to put a drill through
through the chair
I probably can't answer that would have
to talk to the drilling specialists
around that but
um
yeah
going going down to there does add quite
a bit of extra pipe
um and so if we can find a suitable
layer to drill through
um
at Maitland Street then I think that's
certainly going to be preferred
okay
Council Australia
three Mr chair
um is there any sort of feeling as to
why we only had one response to the ROI
on this project
through the sheds down to
the
specialist nature of this work and the
Very specialist equipment required to do
it
um
limited a very obviously very limited
number of contractors with the ability
to do it and to be honest we weren't
surprised that we only got one response
Jason
I'm just to add to that too we did uh
ask those questions of
um of Baker as part of that and they did
State there were other companies that
could do it but again the based North
Island and so bringing them down and
Landing them here you know then it
becomes not as not as reliable for those
to companies to compete in those tenders
so
any any further questions
now would someone like to move that
report be received
babe David wouldn't have come in
thank you
someone like to um
move that report received
it's worship move in and councilor
Fraser signed up all those in favor of
please say aye
against
carried
number eight the material Water
Treatment Plant upgrade
um project that's going going well and
it has gone well I'd say
um Matt any comments
so the chair I'm here with
um progressing through the project
raised me nicely
we are working through some
a pretty critical stage in the project
at the moment we were bringing new
filters online
and commissioning new chemical dosing
systems and things like that
um
and that has requiring our operators to
work in pretty closely with the
contractor
but you're all going well the large
majority of that work should be finished
over the next few weeks and then it'll
just be tidy up work to be completed
there are a couple of
um
items in the scope of the project that
we deliberately left out of the main
contracts and we're looking to engage
local contractors to to undertake that
work and to finish off the project
questions
councilor Phillips
thank you Mr chairman I just got one
question the mcelvey heights
Reservoir did you allow for future
or did you just replace light for lawyer
through the chair we'd replace light for
like
um I would have to go back and look at
um
the
design but I'm I'm pretty sure there
would have been an allowance for future
growth in their
and if if there was needed it wouldn't
be a big job to expand that
um if needed
just what I'm hoping that you're not
that far through
that you have thought about the
expansion expansion and that you've got
at least
one
extra capacity to take in the future you
know like at least one more team for the
future anyway
it just saves you that
just thinking about if you do if it does
expand and possibly May and after my
time I don't know but
um
I just say if you're trying to do all
the public work you know unless you've
got one reservoir
um because as we know mcelvey Heights is
all set up down the bottom
ready for expansion so
thanks
thank you
any other comments on the material water
treatment
one more demo no it's just a thank you
congratulations to the the staff and the
contractors during all the work I'm just
been keeping one me eye on it because
you've probably been passed a couple of
times
um but yeah no it looks looks good
um
gonna be beneficial for material there
has been on on the odd occasion some
dirty water in the pipeline but as I've
explained there's a few of the residents
there's only been one filter running so
look it's probably
going to happen and that happened with
two filters running so
yeah no I think I think all in all I
think residents are
putting out with some good stuff and
because they need to need to see the end
of it
thank you
he's material he compliant before chorus
nice
I just know that it's only taken six
years so it's not too bad
would someone like to move the report be
received Council Phillips as a secondary
for that
councilor mcnell all those in favor of
please say aye
against
carried
hillbry Avenue Pump Station project
number nine on page 31.
um
and back to Matt again for comments
destiny
thank you Mr chairman um yeah I mean
this is um
this project construction is sort of
well underway now and we're expecting a
large majority of the construction work
to be completed over the next few months
um
yeah probably not too much else to
report there but maybe to take any
questions
any questions
pretty straightforward
the only question will be um
as the water towers when where do we put
into the long-term plan yeah
removal but I think that's another
question for another day
when someone have no questions would
someone like to move the report be
received
councilor mcphail a secondary Council of
Australia all those in favor please say
hi
against
carried
David
might want to comment now do you
know
yes did you want to comment on the
reports now and wait till
um
eight eight projects of which the
majority are seed of green
foreign
is that potentially the majority of the
projects are green because the majority
of them are put into the end
so certainly projects actually are due
to be completed within the next six to
seven months so I guess a question I've
got for you
is would it be
would it be or Volume Plus committee to
start to see what other accounts of
projects that Council are starting to
consider because as we all know many of
the issues of many projects actually
on the right of the Inception said
rather than construction is going to
write just now so there you go a little
along when there's a couple to do then
I'll pass it over for you mark
thank you David
um yeah I mean
um you're probably right around the the
um number of green items in there and
the fact that they're getting very close
to completion
um and I I guess it's
uh
you know a mindful
um of
flagging things as as read
um or even orange when when they're not
significant issues which then sort of
becomes a
um
a boy who cried wolf type thing that
um you know you're making a big deal
over
um nothing
um
I mean up until now they have been in in
previous reports that there's certainly
been red items there where we've um been
having issues that we wanted to raise
um but yeah I think
um in general it's it's around that
um
that's the fact that the large majority
of them are nearing completion
um
yeah if there was
um in terms of what the committee should
be worried about
um
the the two projects that that aren't
nearing completion
um
um so that's the matau river crossing
project
um and the Gora matara Wastewater
consent renewal project so they are both
sort of at quite critical stages
the matau river crossing project
obviously it's pretty important that we
find suitable ground conditions and um
metagate as much risk as we can around
the the drilling underneath the river
um and making sure that's successful
um and obviously the gore material waste
would have consent renewal project
um you know that's a massively
significant project for the council or
for the district
um and and some significant financial
um costs associated with the the
potential Solutions
so again making sure that we get those
options right and we fully investigate
them and make sure that that we land on
the best solution for the long term
is pretty important
can I just
challenge that name you just you just
highlighted those two projects as being
the two projects that
respiratory should be more
time yet
both of those projects
already agreement all the way through
clearly we shouldn't be worried about
them at all
um yeah and I guess this is
um
yeah
so the the green May means as expected
and no change from previous reporting
um and and so
when I looked at each of those criteria
at the moment there they are as expected
um
yeah so possibly maybe a suggestion that
we need to change those criteria and
yeah I'm not sure
um
yeah
three was cheap if I can assist I think
and quit from wrong here Matt and to try
and fuse the two views together
um you you look at a dashboard and it
gives you a heads up that things are
predominantly on track what Matt has
described today whoever is that there's
been some late post report completion
developments in regard to the geology of
the year of Maitland Street which places
further um uncertainty on the uh
ultimately the ability to and the cost
involved of direct drilling at that
location is that a fair summation
yeah
through the chair
um yeah
I mean I
I don't think I'm massively concerned
about what we've found at this stage
um but it
it's important that we understand what
is there to make sure that we do
mitigate that risk so but yeah probably
a slightly elevated risk
um
which for your machine which became
known after you actually wrote this
particular report certainly yeah that's
only become apparent last week
counselor Phillips
yeah well I'm thinking in the same way
as David does and I probably think that
maybe some of those greens need to be
half orange half green just put a slash
in between them because when you think
about it if you look at the order
upgrades so Matera front for instance
you're looking at
um new water you're trying to find water
supply so it should be part of the
future developments you'll be part of
that
you're looking at the new res they're
all rear that's not on there as a as a
as a thought for the committee
um
looking at the Des lodging of the second
Bond
that's not in there there should be a a
thought for the future
and the consent is a major one you know
like it's going to be a major one that
one
um the separation of the material pump
stations
you know that's another major cost
coming up in the in the future that we
need to be thinking about
so there is a lot of things in the
project register on these 10 things
items that coexist with what's going in
has to happen in the future and I think
that these should be sort of flagged as
David has pointed out then yeah
um
greens are good but oranges make me
think
Jason
uh through the chair I think some good
points there and I guess coming to the
back end now of what's been a pretty big
Capital project program certainly happy
to have
um discussions with Matt and the team
about what that may look like you know
whether we in terms of the criteria
maybe where whether it's a long-term
process such as material River Crossing
project
you know we might have
um green dots for health and safety and
design and consenting and then leaving
the rest orange because there's a decent
amount of uncertainty about those
projects long term still so not to make
sure you know just we can review that
look at different options
um and just to touch on the the future
looking stuff obviously
um we're in long-term plan process as
well um just about to kick that off and
I have uh just previously had
discussions too with John around the
fact that we this Capital program
project program has been significant for
this team
um and you know certainly swamped our
resources but we are moving into that
stage where we can start to bring you
know a little bit more future thinking
reports to this committee rather than
just you know looking back so I think
there's an opportunity there again not
just for a three Waters team you know
but also for our other asset and
infrastructure projects whether that's
roading
um solid-based you know anything else so
again agree with those comments and
that's something that I work with the
team about how we try and
start to frame up though so it's not all
just reporting that we're starting to
think some bigger picture stuff as well
as part of this committee
that does that answer you some of your
questions David I'd agree with um Jason
on that that there is a future looking
forward is probably going to be very
important especially for the long-term
plan
appreciate that thank you
yes worship
uh thank you Mr chair sorry just on that
Jason will we be able to Loop all of
that redesign of reporting into so we
can get similar stuff for roading and
also solid waste where it's appropriate
so it's all all sounds sort of the same
format as we go through all these
different projects for your team thank
you
thank you
we did we move the last report Susan
we did yes so we'll move move on to gym
and the Murray project stage two
gunny comments do you want to come up to
this
um
and probably the first of the three
faces replacing us in our app project
the um compactors that leave the
building the um
Jim can you grab a mic somewhere here
um essentially we're ready for sign off
The Signal Management and the
contractors who have been incredibly
helpful
have
um
uh essentially left the premises so as
you can see I've given you a breakdown
of the cost
um the cost interestingly
um
the pre-covert estimates and they were
quite detailed
um covert challenged us significantly it
didn't just move the goal posts that
essentially shifted them sideways and
moved them about three miles down the
road but um we were fortunate to be able
to get to this critical phase now with
the support of a variety of funders and
I have to acknowledge Steve Perry Lorne
juicer and hakunu runanga who helped us
significantly on developing the better
off funding component
obviously we had support from kanoa or
the old provincial growth fund
uh the provincial growth fund a
condition of their
contribution to stage one and stage two
that both projects were undertaken
concurrently
so that of course was a challenge in a
post-covert environment but we're very
pleased with the result where we got to
at this stage and we're essentially
regrouping to enact the next three
phases three main phases of the project
the first being the refit of the win
Hamilton wing and that's critical
because this is their one opportunity to
tack in all our vulnerable archives
um that's a fairly straightforward
Enterprise we I mentioned
the display technology in the
exhibitions which we have in hand from
our previous Museum that's all in safe
storage in the library across the road
so we will be re fitting parts of those
displays but will also be reinvigorating
new ones
um
that of course includes the Flaming
smell display that's quite a big and
important one phase 3 will be our main
event which is the journey through the
matara uh Valley and we'll be again
we've worked closely with hokanui
runanga on that
um to get some glorious information and
we will be working with our in-house
team
um Jackie our designer and
um John our fabricator and guest
curators to develop a um a 21st century
Museum telling the mataida valley story
um
I've indicated on the last page
some project Milestones they are all
funding dependent as I mentioned
previously in the report that the budget
that we have scoped for that final fit
out and display will be fundraised
that's working with
the host entities
who have charitable status
who are also currently in receipt of a
number of small individual donations
but in the process of stage one and
stage two we deliberately didn't go near
the lottery grants board Ministry
culture and Heritage a number of other
funders saving them for this last push
and of course the care and
interpretation of collections is what
those funders are focused on so we've
got a um
very suitable and safe premises
um
where we can start hosting hosting
Network so I'm happy to answer any
questions but I think the report is
fairly
um
sufficiently detailed if anybody wants
any more detailed material we've got a
number of progress reports from single
Management Group which have a detailed
outline of progress today
any questions
uh yeah three Mr chair
um so yeah obviously we're getting close
to um
completion of it
um water are going to be our ongoing
costs for this and it's obviously we're
um
we're beholden to a few other parties
with their funding just to finish on the
fit out
um is that guaranteed that it's going to
happen so we haven't got a whole heap of
empty spaces sitting in there
we could fit it out in three months time
with the existing displays that we've
got
um taking into account the 25 years old
and we don't want to inflict the 25 year
old display scenario on um on the good
people of Gore so um
the costings for the for the fit out is
essentially on display lighting
interactive technology which we've
scoped but in saying that we have
significant savings with regard to the
in-house
skills that we've got now with um with
our graphic designer and also with our
fabricator
[Music]
any any further questions
councilman make the noun Jim the last
Grant you got from the MLT is that not
for the fit out was that because you've
got one the other day when we were there
at the whiskey opening that was for the
structural
um phase of the uh and that was to the
gore District Council
Australian well yeah it's through you
you're
um chair
um so one signal sign off on is the
building for
um public use or as I say already in
Pipelines
signals signed it off yes the council
signs it off it's fit for perfect yes
yeah that's right
um with small three very small items
that were required to get a CPU and
they've all been attended to so signal
will be here this week too do a detailed
report and there will be a application
for CPU
okay
I have no further comments
um it's worshiping
uh thank you Mr chair
um a couple of comments uh firstly with
the CPU not coming through till next
week so even estimated official opening
date and ceremony
not not at this fight if you go to the
final page of the report there's an
indication of the key Milestones
um which is the first component that
we've got to attend to as the fit out of
the wind Hamilton wing
and that means essentially gutting the
doubt the ground floor of the wing
shifting everything over to a sphere
space in the middle of my Center fitting
it out and shifting it all back again we
also want to help the visitor center fit
out their um premises when we want to
throw as much support as we can to make
that um a really engaging front of house
we want to action the temporary
exhibition spaces that you'll see on the
floor plan so those temporary exhibition
spaces can
be activated at any time the fit out of
the Fleming's display we want to
um given that we've got some interactive
technology and some other technology
there we want to spend two or three
months working on that we've also got 30
out of the research center which was
critical and that's going to be in the
area adjacent to the journey through the
matala valley
and then we've I've noted from September
24 to December 24 you want Direction the
main displays in the journey through the
Metallo Valley
so there's a there's a bit of work to do
here
we're still still looking so 14 months
40 months out are we ready for
I've I've been here
a fully completed facility that's not to
say that we those aspects of the
facility can be used it's
um certainly a team exhibition play
spaces can be activated
um The Visitor Center is completely free
to
um
working with us
but there will be areas that'll have to
be sectioned off for the for the main
display video
the doors can be open
to cover your question your version
not really Mr chair
um do in that case when will The
Visitors Center likely to be operating
out of out of there
when will staff move from the current
building into the existing or the new
building
aren't we still in discussion about that
that's up to the visitor center really
they need to be we want to give them a
really good home and um and so it's it's
the discussion that we're currently
having between the visitor center and
the department of arts and here at it
foreign
Okay so
we so we don't have a date for when the
doors will be open then because there'll
be nothing in there or are we just
opening the building to
so that people can use it
I'm just a bit confused as to when we'll
be opening it when there'll be something
in there that we can open to the public
or that's still to be discussed be
discussed okay we've got to do it we've
got one chance to do this we'll do it
properly in that case could we get a
supplementary report of when the visitor
center will be moving in there uh and
when the building will be officially
opened um because until then there
really shouldn't be anything going on in
there in an empty building
thank you Mr chair not even not even
work
not not public nothing public should be
going on there
um the other thing is can we please have
uh these reports come to full Council uh
and those signal reports if they come to
full Council as well they've gone
through first committee
the reports from signal as well is the
completion of the works thank you
any other further comments
would someone like to move this report
be received
councilman and councilor Australia
secondary
all those in favor of please say aye
all right against
carried
thank you Jim
uh moving to
item number 11 is the three Waters
quarterly level of service report and uh
presume Aaron Aaron's responsible for
this movie
I met at the exhibit quite quickly
uh thank you Mr chair
um I just want to note that uh uh the
stormwater response to flooding events
we are still working through an issue
with it on on after hours and weekend
time being calculated in that so
hopefully by the next report period that
should be resolved
apart from that the report can be taken
as written
any comments on that report
no comments
looks good
um you've got a bit someone like to move
that that report be received
councilor stronger secondary councilor
Fraser thank you
Andy
um
all those in favor please say hi all
right against
carried
uh I've got to be careful we don't
count the next one is number 12 the
three Waters charity our monthly
compliance
report
um that's straightforward
um thank you Mr chair
um I just want to highlight that
um the ongoing issues that Matera with
the upgrade of the water treatment plant
um and also the hillbry Ave Water
Treatment Plant we do not attempt
protozoa compliance so as soon as we can
get a centralized plant would be good
apart from that I'm happy to answer any
questions
if you read spots here but there's
reasons for that
any questions on anyone
no questions we can move that one
forward
never would it
friend
oh
uh thanks Mr chairman no my question is
about the non-clock non-compliance for
the protozoires is there any
come back from from those for us and the
aspect is
regarding from
the health to our number
number five in the top of the line
which plant
s bison
um through you Mr chair uh no there's no
coming on that
um once we get the centralized plant for
Hillary Ave
um and that plant is decommissioned we
will meet protozoa compliance
at each school is for Matera once that
plant is fully commissioned
we will be meeting all drinking water
standards requirements
um with that plant it's only when
we have any Telemetry hiccups at the
moment at Matera is why we become
non-compliant
foreign
we start getting some wild rumors out
there in material in the in the district
about if it came out about if people
read this report about the
non-compliance for the protozoas that we
probably might need to do a bit of um
publicity saying that the water is still
safe it's just a big deal at the end of
the line so
yeah just for the layperson that might
ask that that question
for your comment
um yes Sonia might want to put something
together
with Aaron and um explain away what's
happened here because basically it's a
red non-compliant but we're definitely
right on track to get this filled in
yeah and I think it could be a good
opportunity too for uh just to
compliment the material people and and
the hilbria ones as well that we score
the residents they're thinking for
putting up with the situation at the
moment but their water's still
uh safe to drink but you know during
this period of
of building or Redevelopment
no friend of comments
in your scholarship okay uh thank you Mr
chair not uh directly related to this
report but just um while I had the
opportunity
um just if there was any updates on the
the developing situation with the
sulfuric acid stuff
or a bit so only control
[Music]
uh thank you Mr worship uh Mr chairman
uh
the instant report has just come through
into my emails
um prior to this meeting I had met with
um environment Southland at the gore
Wastewater Pond
um and we have gone through our own
sampling and they have done these and
both parties cannot find any remnants or
any effects in the in the river
um
the
investigation report that I've received
and I will be reviewing that overnight
and we'll have an update it's on stage
tomorrow morning for the elected members
appreciate that thanks Aaron and sorry
for putting into the pump to see we
appreciate the update I've been
reasonably busy this morning and Neville
um councilor folks
they give us a chair so uh is the money
set aside to mitigate the
the problem in the future
is it solvable quite quickly
through you Mr chair
um at this stage
um the outcome I have not read the
incident report so I wouldn't want to
predetermine anything at this stage
thank you
no further comments
someone like to move the report report
be received as worship a secondary
councilor Phillips all those in favor
please say hi
all right against
carried
now we'll flick over to
I've got um the material oxidation pond
discharge annual monitoring report
here and again
uh thank you Mr chair
um at this stage I just want to
introduce you to Amy Amy is our three
Waters senior compliance officer and I'm
sure we'll actually answer any questions
in regards to this report
uh so yeah thank you Mr chair
um I'll take the report as read I guess
on a high level overview uh we are
reporting is fully compliant against our
matoda Wastewater discharge into the
matoda river
um but you're happy to take any
questions
any questions on this one
councilor mcfarrell I'm not really
questions uh through your uh cheer there
sorry uh
um all I'd like to say is I read right
through this and I spent most of the
afternoon going from this to a
dictionary to work out what everything
means I've learned a lot about Alvey and
things like that that I really
appreciate now and it's a comprehensive
report so thank you for it
it's a lot of ready in there
um
any any further comments
for Amy
if that's the case would someone like to
move that this report be received
councilor mcfarl there's a secondary
accounts for Fraser
and all those in favor please say hi
caged it's carried we'll just conclude
the meeting here and then we'll move
into
um
in committee
so just wait a few minutes whenever we
break
and we've got two two reports to cover
in committee